it's time to talk about the cost of
living about prices and wages those two
things interact and they affect how
well-off we're feeling how much money we
have left to spend after our wages and
our taxes uh in the real economy and
real wages which gives you a sense of
just how much money we have when you've
adjusted for inflation we'll have a look
back over the last few years at how it
behaves because this is a big part of
the story about where we are now
the year 2000 to 2008 they were rising
pretty steadily and if they're carried
on rising like that then the line would
have gone up like that you would have
been talking about 600 pounds a week in
real terms
but look what actually happened they
basically flatlined they went along
there so they really didn't rise over
that entire period you had this lost
decade of growth the biggest squeeze
that we've ever seen and more recently
look there is a glimmer of light because
there has been a bit of an increase but
the question is whether that's primarily
down to covid and whether it actually
endures and you've got a lot of things
that are interacting here higher wages
but also
now higher inflation have a look at this
this shows you gas prices wholesale gas
prices that we pay in the uk they're at
the highest level we have ever seen
they've come down a little bit just in
the last week or so but nonetheless
incredibly high that's feeding into all
of our builds as are these things these
are global prices of a few important
things metals up by 77 since covert 19
struck crude oil prices 200 percent
since covid food prices 40
in any given period by the way 40 would
be considered very high uh but just look
at this overall
shipping price is up by 400 so there's a
lot of talk about lorry drivers about
the difficulty of getting things from
one place to another in this country
it's a global situation and that is
feeding into all of our prices and it's
pushing up inflation now the bank of
england says that cpi inflation which is
this thing here just the you know the
annual rate at which prices are rising
shouldn't get too high but here's the
thing they've said that before they said
back in may it wasn't going to go it was
going to go to 2.2 percent then it went
even higher than that then they said it
wasn't going to go beyond 3.3 then it
went even higher than that and now
they say it's gonna go above four
percent so a lot of people wonder
whether inflation is back we'll be
keeping an eye on that in the coming
months